first former eight news now i-team we
now know the name of the person accused
of stabbing this dog that later died
from his injuries and this is a story
that got a lot of attention as it was
hurt and eventually passed away
protecting his owner right now a warrant
is out for the person police say did
this the i-team's david charns here with
this i-team exclusive kirsten denise you
may remember this story from last year
it's the case of alexander it drew
widespread praise after police said the
dog was protecting his owner during that
fight while the i-team checked in on
this case and we've since learned police
are now looking for a man named
shaquille walsh documents obtained by
the eight news now i-team indicating
walsh is accused of stabbing alexander
with a six-inch knife
the animal foundation describing
alexander as a hero for possibly saving
his owner's life walsh has no criminal
record here in our area and there is no
photo of him to show you
right now he is wanted on charges of
battery and animal cruelty now you may
be asking yourself why animal cruelty if
prosecutors haven't pressed charges in
some other of these high-profile animal
deaths the death of tina tintor's dog
max in that crash involving x-rayed or
henry ruggs may come to mind well animal
cruelty laws in nevada are written only
in cases where the act is intentional as
if the person knew they would be harming
or killing an animal right now there was
a warrant out for walsh's arrest you can
always leave a tip anonymously by
calling or texting crime stoppers i'm
david charns live local now